michael was an amazing husband author
and provider the community is
remembering nevada highway patrol
trooper micah may
good evening and thanks so much for
joining us at six i'm vanessa murphy
and i'm christian casadas today the
community gathered for a procession
through the valley
a service was held for may at central
church in henderson
hundreds were in attendance according to
joe muller who gives us a look at how
may
was remembered
he genuinely loved helping
and protecting people and showed it
in the way he treated the public a
community says goodbye to a fallen hero
i doubt but only the minute few
would step out as he did
and more than once i have been told he
did so
from las vegas mayor carolyn goodman to
the head of the nevada highway patrol
colonel and carpenter
local leaders wanted to honor the man
who leaves behind a wife and children
to his wife joanna kids raylan and
melody
you carry his name which will live on
through the children he loves so dearly
it was his family trooper may saw just
before his life was taken
just before trooper may went on his last
call he learned that his family was
shopping
and surprised them all during his break
he left though because he felt like he
was needed by his fellow troopers
that one snapshot in a life that by all
accounts was truly honorable
speaks volumes for him both of may's
brothers shared stories about their
childhoods together
we've spent a lot of time in the woods
too micah loved to find
the tallest trees and climb them
and he would climb all the way to the
top and never show any fear of heights
trooper may was described as a patriot
and a hero he did not only protect and
save lives during his
career he also saved more after trooper
may's final act of grace ended with the
donation of his heart
liver and both kidneys which saved four
lives joe mohler 8 news now a truly
emotional day for sure well you can tell
how appreciated trooper may was
a lot of people stopped to salute the
procession and law enforcement agencies
from all over the country
were here to honor him as well